good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP 662 object class
safe special containment procedures SCP
662 should be kept in its red velvet
lined case and stored in high-value
storage locker 23 C located at when not
being used for testing or other
appropriate activities the item itself
is safe to handle and poses no known
threats of any kind though the effects
generated could be considered highly
valuable and variably powerful depending
on how the SCP is used description
scp-666 enta metres tall and 2
centimeters in circumference the bell is
missing its ringer within the inside of
the Bell an inscription has been etched
into the silver reading forever mine s
JW the Bell is susceptible to damage
however given its nature destruction has
been deemed unnecessary as it is made of
very pure silver it requires regular
polishing to remain without tarnish when
the Bell is shaken as if to ring it a
soft chime can be heard although this
does not come from the Bell a short
well-dressed Caucasian Butler of
self-proclaimed British heritage calling
himself mr. deeds will appear from the
nearest area not within line of sight
usually from around a corner mr. deeds
will address the ringer of the Bell by
their appropriate title and their last
name and asked what they desire his
knowledge of individuals last names and
titles is a mystery as he himself will
purport see interview log 662 l1
for further details most reasonable
requests given to mr. deeds will and
result in satisfaction however there are
limits to what he can do he is unable to
produce very complex items such as
sports cars luxury homes or personal
Jets if he is allowed to leave
line-of-sight and return he is able to
produce smaller less complex items such
as a ham sandwich a glass of iced tea or
even more luxurious items like caviar or
a brick of gold a list of notable items
the butler has thus far been able to
provide to those who ring the bell may
be found in addendum 662 a 1 mr. deeds
will also perform menial tasks such as
washing vehicles preparing food and
cleaning bathrooms if a request is
deemed unreasonable or impossible by the
butler he will kindly tell the ring or
so and offer an alternative if one may
be had the butler is not immune to ill
actions taken against him while in sight
he has been killed or injured in
multiple tests and will remain either
dead or injured until he is out of sight
upon return with a ring of the Bell all
previous injuries will have vanished and
he will be groomed and well dressed in
his uniform and ready for the next order
a more detailed explanation of the jobs
he can perform and the limits to which
he may be put can be found in the
affirmation interview log 662 l1 test
logs relating to his ability to heal
himself and those of the properties of
the Bell may be accessed by any level 2
personnel or higher all attempts to
catch mr. deeds disappearing have failed
as equipment will either fail or he will
find a suitable unobserved spot addendum
662 a 1 items and tasks are requested
and results
items nearly any conceivable kind of
sandwich human flesh has been requested
as lunch meat and politely denied
beverages also of nearly any kind as
with sandwich made human blood has been
requested and denied pig blood however
was served promptly still warm a brick
of 99.98% pure gold mr. deeds produced a
brick of 99.1 4% pure gold and
apologized for being unable to provide
the requested purity a brick of
ninety-nine point two four percent pure
silver a nuclear bomb politely denied a
hand grenade of modern US military grade
which performed as expected in testing a
blue 1963 Corvette Convertible politely
denied the board game Monopoly which mr.
deeds won on the first play through a
Faberge egg politely denied SCP politely
denied a bouquet of fresh picked red
roses and a bouquet of wild turn bus
tease politely denied turn bus t is not
an actual known type of flower tasks
cleaning of dr. mirth scar performed to
near perfection washing of dishes
accumulated from a day's worth of meals
from the cafeteria on that were
performed to much higher standards than
usual trimming of dr. Mertz hair
performed but it turns out that mr.
deeds is not in fact a very good barber
washing of dr. Mertz laundry performed
and the clothing found to fit better in
dr. Mertz estimation assassination of
Osama bin Laden politely denied mr.
deeds claimed bin Laden was too
well-guarded and entrenched but could
not or would not give further details
assassination of a d-class individual
our room over performed with vicious
precision using a buck knife to the
throat note further tests with regards
to dr. Mertz personal effects are to be
forbidden unless approved by one level
of five overseer you have been warned
dr. mirth interview logs interview 662
l1 an interview with mr. deeds an entity
associated with SCP 662 firstly may I
have your name certainly you may call me
mr. Dees is that your real name it is my
birthday no sir what would that be and
where are you four unfortunately I
cannot remember my full names nor am i
positive of my birthplace though I do
believe it to be located in England do
you recall when you were born
mr. needs I am truly sorry to disappoint
again sir but I do not recall that
either though it's must have been some
time ago but I don't believe I was born
in this era can you approximate again
sir I apologize for my lack of
self-knowledge I'm a bit of a shut-in
as you know what is the earliest mode of
transportation that you can recall
seeing in person or utilizing from the
past horse and buggies although bicycles
were just becoming a fad with the word
Nicolle currently I took off Vanessa you
needn't call me sir any longer and I
appreciate it but it's becoming a little
grating very well why do you suppose you
cannot remember these things I don't
quite say or is it that you may or will
not say that's maybe the case yes but
that's not I may not say again begging
your pardon I dunno the cold one that it
is very well
moving on whatever is it that you go to
when you fetch items for those you serve
well you see I do not actually recall
that either
why do you wince why I ask these kinds
of questions
I do not know never mind that for now
we'll get answers eventually now that I
have a request
how may I be of further assistance I
would like a glass of iced tea grab a
glass for yourself if you like
what kind of iced tea would you prefer
surprise me mr. deeds stood and walked
to the door of the interrogation room
and tried to handle finding it locked
turned and smiled at dr. mirth what
seems to be the problem
I must leave your presence to do as you
request why is that it just is enough
mr. deeds left the room he proceeded
down the hallway under video
surveillance via camera
and agent graves he paused momentarily
at another door shook his head looked up
at the camera and then at agent graves
then he ran down the hallway and rounded
the corner agent graves did not follow
as he had been instructed to remain on
guard at the door of the interrogation
room
still under camera surveillance mr.
deeds proceeded quickly down the next
hall and continued throughout the halls
of the complex presumably searching for
an exit or area not under surveillance
finally he stopped halfway down corridor
to D at this point all three cameras in
corridor to D malfunction including two
that were hidden exactly three minutes
later the cameras resumed normal
functioning revealing mr. deeds standing
in the same position but with a tray
holding two glasses of iced tea in hand
he then quickly made his way back to the
interrogation room mr. deeds placed a
glass in front of dr. mirth and resumed
his seat at the other end of the table
dr. mirth hesitantly sniffed the tea
smiled and took a sip this is perhaps
sweet tea I've ever had delicious did
you make it yourself
I do dislike disappointing you dr. mirth
but I do not recall I assume that I did
about Alice my mind is not what it used
to be you've only been gone about ten
minutes mr. deeds are you telling me
that your memory is so terrible that you
cannot remember what happened ten
minutes ago
or the time in between I recall looking
for a way out and I recall returning
with the tea but that is all but not how
or where you acquired the tea
unfortunately no very well I have
another request as you wish I was like a
bar of gold
what percentage of pureness would you
like 99.98% if
please that may be possible let me see
what I can do well disable the cameras
in the hall outside and agent graves
will wait in the interrogation room with
me to make your trip a little faster
this time very much appreciated
shall i yes mr. deeds exited into the
hallway where despite what dr. mirth
claimed the cameras were not turned off
he paused for a moment looked up at the
closest camera shook his head and began
travelling through the hallways of the
complex as before in corridor to be a
pause and once more all cameras hidden
or visible in the corridor malfunction
exactly 10 minutes and 37 seconds later
the cameras began functioning again to
show mr. deeds once again in the same
position with a bar of gold in one hand
he then returned to the interrogation
room well it seems that the cameras in
the hallway remained open so I have to
find a suitable way out again I do
apologize for the delay sir also I was
not able to acquire a bar of gold to the
pureness that you requested but I assure
you that this bar is 99214 percent pure
very impressive well we test aunt
Hampshire you know I did don't know that
you would it makes sense I suppose will
there be anything else dr. mirth yes
for your next task I would like you to
acquire for me a blue 1963 Corvette
Convertible I am quite sorry but that is
not possible why not I really want one
again I cannot say why except that I
just know one cannot be gulten via my
methods and what are those methods I do
know her goals it very well I would like
a Faberge egg any will do ah well
regretfully that is impossible as well
and I suppose you cannot say why and
that is correct sir how about some
caviar any brand or type we'll do that I
can mr. deeds once more entered the
hallway outside the interrogation room
this time the cameras were turned off
after visual confirmation of mr. deeds
entry into the hall one minute later the
cameras were turned back on but mr.
deeds had already returned to the
interrogation room at this point that
was considerably faster mr. deeds and
only took you 30 two seconds caviar is
quite good I am pleased to hear it sir
one more thing before we in this session
mr. gates as you wish I request that you
assassinate oh I'm afraid mr. deeds once
again entered the hallway after visual
confirmation
the cameras were momentarily turned off
when turned back on they revealed the
door to the next interrogation room down
shutting the cameras in that
interrogation room showed mr. deeds
entering the room with a large buck
knife hidden behind one arm mr. deeds
approached the waiting d-class personnel
and deftly slit his throat with one
quick motion of the knife mr. deeds
watched as the d-class personnel went
through the motions of death avoiding
their attempts to grab him once the
d-class individual was visually presumed
dead mr. deeds returned to the
interrogation room from some point
please wait here until I return dr.
mirth and agent graves leave the room
dr. mirth returns two hours later video
surveillance shows that mr. deeds did
not move during this interval mr. deeds
my colleagues and I have some
disagreements about you that's most
unfortunate we feel these disagreements
can only be resolved by examining you
more intensely sadly I don't have to be
specific we'd like to examine you
internally certainly doctor both we'd
like to do an autopsy
ah shall I kill myself for you and since
you will be examining my internal organs
do you have a preferred method for my
death yes if that's possible
Oh certainly it is possible doctor that
might I suggest having me cut my own
throat so that I am excited the buck
knife from when I killed mr. infinitely
at hand and although other methods are
of course available they would either
take longer or damage my organ such that
they are no longer accurately
representative of my pre-mortem state I
I suppose wait yes before you do it you
will come back afterward correct I'm
sorry
don't do it I don't quite understand
after the pawnshop incident when you
were killed you came back to life
afterward when sergeant bell and a few
say so give us will you come back to
life again I have no idea doctor if I do
before then presumably I will again
unless something strange
have you any further questions before I
make the incision I do recommend you
step back as I would hate for my blood
to soil your clothing death rows can be
untidy no I suppose not
carry on very well dr. Matt and in the
event that I doomed to come back to life
it has been a genuine pleasure mr. deeds
then sliced his own throat and bled to
death a post-mortem examination of the
body revealed it to be ordinary in every
way though it is noted that mr. deeds
was not suffering from any noticeable
disease or physical condition and was in
fact a near-perfect health at the time
of death the contents of his stomach
consisted of southern-style sweet tea
normal stomach acids and no more mr.
deeds bonnie was then left on the
operating table while the lights in the
room and cameras were turned off all
personnel left the room and upon return
no trace of mr. deeds be it blood on the
instruments used or other physical
traces such as organs removed let alone
the actual body remain further ringing
of scp-616 resulted in mr. deeds
appearance after three minutes he showed
no signs of injury and was well dressed
once more in a modern uniform commonly
worn by Butler's as expected he could
not explain how he managed to survived
he was then ordered to give dr. mirth a
full-body massage which he performed
much to dr. mirth satisfaction dr. mirth
claimed it was the best damn rubdown
I've ever had my back pain is completely
gone
acquisition report scp-616 the
possession of a petty thief and grave
robber in USA the thief was in the
process of selling as CP 662 to a pawn
shop in the mentioned town when the bell
was accidentally rung by the pawn shop
attendant mr. deeds appeared from the
storage area behind the counter and
promptly addressed the attendant
believing that he was about to be robbed
by the two men the attendant overreacted
and managed to get hold of a sawed-off
shotgun from under the counter mr. Dees
was fatally wounded by the attendant and
died on scene
the thief escaped but was apprehended by
foundation agents after a week-long
search of the surrounding towns under
questioning the thief revealed that he
found the Bell in its box in the grave
located in the outskirts of the
above-mentioned town he was then
remitted for d-class personnel
assignment and subsequently perished
during testing of SCP the Bell did not
come under the purview of the foundation
until after the crime and subsequent
transport of mr. deeds body to the local
morgue after the disappearance of the
body from the morgue an agent was sent
to investigate the possible outbreak of
SCP or other unknown and chronic
reinvigorating caused mr. deeds
reappeared in the case file items
storage room of the local constabulary
after the bell was handled by sergeant
he was quickly apprehended and agent
took him into custody three hours after
reappearance under the guise of an FBI
agent when the handcuffed mr. deeds once
again disappeared the agent did too did
that the Bell itself may have something
to do with the string of incidents and
after acquiring it and testing his
proved hunch brought the Bell back to
for further testing agent
awarded an official foundation pat on
the back plaque for his handling of the
incident and lack of self-serving
interest once he discovered what the
Bell and mr. deeds were capable of God
dr. mirth I can't believe this guy got
away with that for three times he got
his laundry done he got a haircut and he
got his car clean what the hell man also
I want one of those pat on the back
plaques pat on the back plaques pat on
the back plates that sounds weird saying
it like that a plaque that says pat on
the back I want one of those anyway I
think that about does it for today thank
you all for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Bob the reclusive extrovert James
Sabah Chris all hens I'd Pablo ice 917
Karim L ash mooing Justin day Thomas
Morin Curie kuma white crew and jayvo
Jack crystal spice my archive curator
Nick Joseph Lewis ooh eggy King modding
and the wanderer thank you all so much
for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos well and some other
cool stuff as well visit patreon.com
forward slash the volga thank you